>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHY WE
WOULD BRING IN PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT GRATEFUL TO BE A CITIZEN.
YOU ARE DEFINITELY IN THAT
CATEGORY.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME, THANKS.
AND COULTER JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU HAVE A GREAT PIECE ON
LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO WON THE 2016
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT, HAS A RIGHT TO
IMPOSE HIS IMMIGRATION VIEWS ON
THE COUNTRY.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> FIRST, I WANT TO SAY,
DONALD TRUMP IS RIGHT.
THESE DREAMERS ARE FABULOUS,
THEY'RE GREAT, THEY'RE
FANTASTIC.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THEM TO BE OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS.
I THINK EVERY CITY IS WONDERING,
HIM TO BE NEGOTIATING THIS?
HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT, HE GOT
LITERALLY ZERO VOTES, WAS THE
FIRST AND MOST VICIOUS AND
TABLE AT ALL ON EMIGRATION
NEGOTIATIONS, MUCH LESS HE'S THE
AS A SAY IN MY COLUMN, IT DOES
MAKE ANY NORMAL OBSERVER THINK
SENATORS ALLOWING THIS WESTERN
MARK IF IT HAD BEEN FACT
DROPPING THE IRAQ WAR, THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE ALLOWED THE
WAR.
WHY IS THE MEDIA TALKING TO HIM,
WHY IS THE PRESIDENT TALKING TO
HIM?
THE DONORS WANT THE CHEAP LABOR.
THE ONE THING THAT'S GOING TO BE
FUN IF WE LOSE THIS IS WATCHING
ALL OF THESE SHORTSIGHTED,
IDIOTIC BUSINESSMEN TRY TO DO
BUSINESS IN A COUNTRY RUN BY THE
LIKES OF NANCY PELOSI.
>> Tucker: THAT WILL BE
AMUSING, BUT SAD FOR THE REST OF
US.
IT'S A DEEPER QUESTION ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
IF THE PUBLIC HAD BEEN CLEAR AND
POLL AFTER POLL AND IT WENT
THROUGH THE TROUBLE OF ELECTING
DONALD TRUMP AGAINST ALL ODDS
AND ALL PREDICTIONS, JUST TO
EXPRESS THAT VIEW, IT STILL
CAN'T GET WHAT IT
DEMONSTRATIVELY WANTS AND
THIS?
>> IT NO, IT'S AMAZING.
IT'S BEYOND WHAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED.
I WAS LOOKING THROUGH
TRANSCRIPTS TODAY.
THE FACT THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
PRESIDENT, IT WAS UTTERLY
IMPLAUSIBLE.
IT WAS LIKE A HOLLYWOOD MOVIE.
THIS IS IN THE FIRST TIME.
YOU HAVE THESE PHONY POLLS BEING
CITED BY THE MEDIA.
EVERY TIME THEY HAVE AN ACTUAL
AGAINST ILLEGAL SPIRIT THEY'LL
VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP, THEY'LL
VOTE FOR ENGLISH AS THE NATIONAL
LANGUAGE.
A POLL JUST CAME OUT THAT SHOWED
MORE AMERICANS WOULD LIKE ZERO
IMMIGRATION THAN OUR CURRENT
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
THE WAY THEY PULL OFF THESE
PHONY POLES, THIS IS NOT A GOOD
WAY TO TAKE A POLE, THEY
PERSONALIZE IT.
THEY SAY DO YOU WANT TO SUPPORT
JUANITA THE MAID?
THEY MAKE IT ABOUT A PERSON.
I WANT QUESTIONS LIKE DO YOU
WANT MORE OR LESS IMMIGRATION?
CITIZENS AND COLLECT WELFARE
RIGHT AWAY?
SHOULD WE BE DROPPING MILLIONS
OF LOW-WAGE WORKERS ON THE
COUNTRY?
SOME PEOPLE THINK HE IS A GENIUS
AN END SOME WAYS HE IS.
HE HAS AN UNCANNY SENSE FOR
POPULAR ISSUES, THAT'S WHY HE
WON.
HE MAY BE ABLE TO ROLL OVER THE
NEVER >> Tucker: THANK YOU FOR